[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream q a segment 117 not
prime but odd
so on okay come on
here we go
from the discord this week and it is
about the fact that it is from the
discord in some ways and we alluded to
this last week but yep here you go you
know you know what the question is um
will the darkhorse podcast have to move
to a new platform now that discord has
bent the knee and there's a link to an
article in the verge the first paragraph
of which reads
after two years of pandemic discord is
making its policies more clear about
health misinformation
in new community guidelines which go
into effect on march 28th discord says
users quote may not share false or
misleading information on discord that
is likely to cause physical or societal
harm
end quote this includes content that
could result in damage to physical
infrastructure injury to others and
content that endangers wait for it
public health
one has to wonder
what the people who make these policies
understand about how the world works
they are 24 and they've been miseducated
and you know these these these uh
say pronouns these um
millennials prefixes prefixes
no it's not millennials who is 24 at
this point these um
uh these prefixes miss dis and mal are
now of course completely tainted um but
they have been miseducated
and they're young and the combination
uh means that you put them in charge and
you give them power
and you know of course they're gonna
make totalitarian and insane rules
i i have to say i can't accept this i
i don't i didn't say it was cool no no
oh you don't like you don't think the
answer is right
is that right right okay
how do they think we come to understand
what's true in the first place it's
religion
it is it's it's a religion and it
imagines that those people who believe
the one true thing have been served by
god or something and it's they don't
call it god because they don't think
they're religious it's part you know
part of what's going on these are people
who explicitly largely don't think
they're religious at all they think they
don't have faith and this is a you know
question on which you have
you and i but you especially have talked
and thought a lot
and so that they you know they are the
recipient of the of the one true faith
and they don't think it's faith
and um therefore what they do to inform
those of us who haven't seen the light
is just
forcing on us like hammered into our
brains or something
well
they don't have a model beyond that of
how it is that we come to understand
things
okay that's possible i think that is
possible there's also another
possibility
which is
back in the dark days after 9 11
the
tech companies
were handed
mandates
with absolutely
uh
draconian types of coercion they were
effectively told
you must hand over data on
your customers and if you tell anyone
that you have been forced to hand over
data then you are guilty of uh
supporting terrorism tech companies you
said are like phone companies because
there weren't there wasn't yeah this was
pre facebook
i'm not saying tech platforms i'm saying
uh it was
phone community comms yeah communication
companies yeah and so the point is if
somebody comes to you and they say well
you are required by law to hand over
this thing and you are required by law
not to tell anyone that you've handed
over this thing
um and if you do hand it over then
you're actually helping the terrorists
and we have this law that makes you
vulnerable to all sorts of so useful
right so the question is
is something like that taking place here
where discord
which is after all a
mechanism for gamers to talk to each
other that has been adopted by others
but
it doesn't have any business deciding
what's true and what's not true that's
not what it's for
we can't have
companies that make paper decide they're
not going to sell paper to people who
write bad ideas on it
you know it can't have an opinion and
yet it seems to and the question is does
it have an opinion because the people
who
run it are
that is there a nice synonym for dumb
because it's really dumb to think that
that you could actually run a society in
which you're not allowed to discuss the
possibility that the officials are wrong
is batshit crazy considered a nice
synonym
i like it okay um but
the basic point is i don't know whether
this is
the behavior of people
who are
confronted with um
and uh
some kind of coercion that we can't see
or is this actually them being brown
shirts and
doing the bidding of something
well
i guess i would also ask if those are
two fully distinct categories i don't
think they are
no i think they are i think i say them
again i mean you know
maybe i don't know my history well
enough but my sense is that brown shirts
are effectively um not coerced into
brown shirting they are and they are
conscious of the of what they are
enacting
they are they are taking it upon
themselves to advance the policy okay
okay um so i guess i was i was hearing
like brown shirty behavior um but yeah
you know
people people come to be true believers
and may not be in the employ of
something that is forcing them in any
way but uh they come to you know welcome
more and more of the role that they had
adopted with unwittingly at first yeah i
mean it is it is in fact just simply a
kind of
fascism where effectively the the
powerful nation becomes
a bludgeon and it you know goes after
uh
entities that cannot protect themselves
so the short answer yep for the discord
folks
is that we certainly need a backup plan
and probably need to
enact it because
so that's
let me do this
we need a short-term back-up plan right
away and uh
we are working on it we need a
longer-term plan uh that
will be immune
to such coercion but of course it needs
to be immune at all the layers and um
part of the call for web developers from
a few weeks ago and now we don't need
any more we had so many amazing
applicants um is in part
um
in service of potentially building um
yeah you know at the moment discord is a
perk of being on our patreons
um and is where the dark horse community
lives
and um if we had something that was
independent of discord and of patreon
and you know of of all of all of these
sort of sorts of tech platforms which
are demonstrably censorious which are
like eagerly censorious now uh
the community would be more robust and
we would as well and so obviously that's
something that we want it will take time
to build um
but uh it is it is the long-term plan to
do so and we also need a short-term uh
backup and we are um we're working on
that as well
yeah it's the male information that gets
you
it's always something
all right first question from
thedarkhorsesubmissions.com site for
this week
on a rare early 60 degree day i opted to
take a bike ride and upon entering the
outside and open trail i passed a woman
and small child wearing masks they were
faceless other than their hollow eyes
i felt myself sigh deeply and then
filled with anger and rage
after 30 years working for a small
company we are closing they took so much
i am judging others i am angry at they
is it misdirected am i a horrible person
am i a feature or a bug
love to you both
such an amazing
you know brief soliloquy and i think
while the
this is the work of poetry and of
literature right here is that there was
a particular experience that you had
and it is it speaks to a general human
experience that so many of us are having
now that you know the the particular
describes
and evokes the universal uh and are you
a horrible person no are are
all of us i expect having moments um
hopefully not whole days or weeks or
months but at least moments
of rage and of anger uh now yeah i
assume that almost everyone
is and rage and anger are i think
you know
never the best approach but
um
but the faceless other than the hollow
eyes the small company that closes after
30 years because how could you possibly
withstand
this this level of coercion
and
arbitrariness
absent having a sideway in to to get
perks that you never needed because you
were doing honorable work and
as long as
there was freedom to explore and expand
and innovate you could do it
of course there will be some anger and
rage and again it's not the best
the best the most effective response but
um recognizing that can be and then
diverting it but i'm not sure to what
you know i don't i don't know what
what all the responses should be at this
point
um
personally i'm having
difficulty
i'm pretty good at managing my anger
until we get to the kids
and
the problem
with
the anger
which i think is justly
justly deployed on behalf of the
children
is that their parents are culpable
and not fully culpable they've been
they've been duped many of them they've
been duped but i mean basically it comes
down to this
the parents have an obligation to
protect their children from
predatory stuff
and
that means that it's also your
obligation to be on the lookout for
predatory stuff and to the extent that
we have
adults
masking their children outside
i don't think you were on the lookout
i think if you were on the lookout you'd
know that outside was safe and you would
understand that your child benefits from
not being trained into the expectation
of wearing a mask
and so it's not that i don't have
i have
unlimited forgiveness for anyone
who was fooled without being willing to
be fooled but i feel like there's too
much willingness
to be fooled there's too much what
what's the distinction you're making i'm
not i'm not sure yet if you were
actually fooled
that's not on you but if you avoided the
information that said something is wrong
here actually my child is safe several
times over they're healthy
they're young
and we're talking about outdoors
and what's more even if i as a parent
don't know what to make of the
developmental hazard of masks i know
that some people think that there might
be some then the point is you might
try to make a rule that said well how
about just indoors why don't you make
sure to take that thing off every time
we're outdoors
as you walk back and forth to school
take it off but inside wear it right if
you made that rule i think you're still
making an error but the point is it's an
error you tried to do the right thing
and you just drew the line in a place
that i don't think is the right one so
maybe
so i'm trying to figure out how you
would operationalize your your
distinction between willingly fold and i
don't know exactly what like just
unwillingly fold or something so it
doesn't quite it doesn't quite track for
me
i think in part because um
maybe what i just heard was did you draw
any line at all
if you drew no line if if you
accepted
the changing rhetoric and policies every
single time it came and even when it was
clearly in contradiction with previous
things and there had been nothing to
explain the discrepancy
um then then you're in the simply fooled
camp and but if you drew any line at all
no matter
how insipid that line may seem to some
of us but if you were assessing if you
were doing some assessment and working
on behalf of of your child
and your child's future to um to not
have them be dragged down with whatever
this madness is then then you are more
forgiving is that is is it is it about
having drawn any line at all i'll even
go one step further i think if you tried
to draw a line you'd draw a line but if
you thought about well should i draw a
line and you looked at it and you
thought actually no their line is about
right that's still
you know you put in the work
right and it's not that i honor the work
itself but the point is yeah
that's that's a funny thing for you to
say after the last hour well but my
point is you actually did you were
willing to draw a line yeah you just
didn't find the line to draw and so well
but then this this is where i find it
difficult to to operationalize because
everyone will claim we see this right
like everyone will go well you know i
was i was skeptical back then and you
know we'll see the most authoritarian
lockstep yahoos claiming that because
you know the placement of a comma in
some tweet indicates skepticism from two
years ago right like everyone is going
to re-envision their own history and
proclaim that they were the ones who
were
you know doing the equivalent of taking
risks to protect people i i don't think
it's so difficult because i think what
actually happened is that an awful lot
of people
are
engaging in the equivalent of
taking a bribe
the parents are selling out their own
children
in order to look virtuous in the eyes of
strangers yep and that is not honorable
right the point is you actually have an
obligation to absolutely ignore what
strangers think of you in order to
protect your child and the idea and you
know we see the same thing with the
trans stuff that's exactly i mean that
that that reveals it
that that's shocking right that parents
are willing to um give their children
puberty blockers and their adolescents
cross-sex hormones and let them get
mutilating surgeries that almost
guarantee sterility and a lifetime of of
hell
right
that's much farther yep than
what most parents have been doing who've
just been following along with the cdc
and just trust all the authorities right
so maybe at some level why are we
surprised like we we have already been
living for many years a complete
hellscape with a tiny fraction granted
of parents who are willing to to do
total abominations to their children
well but let's let's make the model
complete the point is you've got a
gradient
right how
how far are you falling down on your
parental obligation
right and the point is we had people who
were ahead of the curve who were falling
down on their obligation to the level
that they were allowing medical
mutilation of their children
as a result of some brand new
sophistication that they were told was a
deep insight into human sexuality and
that's obviously an egregious breach
right right this was much easier right
it was much easier for somebody who
might have called foul on that to go
along with the cdc's nonsense on masks
to a degree but again the point is
i think a lot of people fell down at one
of two levels either they were
corruptable because it was so delightful
to
broadcast your virtue via mask or
whatever and broadcast your you know
your commitment to the community by
masking your child or something like
that so there were people who
fell victim to an incentive effectively
an emotional bribe
and betrayed their children because of
that and then there were other people
who
were just paralyzed by not knowing
what to think about corrupted
authorities
what would you do you know if the
authority
is actually a menace to your child and
they they just didn't have the
architecture which is a smaller well
failure
smaller
than accepting a an emotional bribe to
betray your child
well i yeah i mean i guess we should
probably move on but i i
i think i would approach it differently
and i think um in fact
i i do
you know as
we have said many many times
we understand trans to be an exceedingly
rare but real
condition that in some cases actually
has to do with genetic anomalies
and
and it is the completely novel the hyper
novel way that
really 21st century but some degree late
20th century um westerners have decided
to deal with it that is the the giant
freaking problem the medicalization
through puberty blockers through
cross-sex hormones and through surgery
of something that is for the vast
majority of people who experience any
kind of gender dysphoria
going to be fleeting
and they will recover and they will be
fine unless they've had a medicalization
of of what has happened
but that has been in the water
hopefully not literally but you know
hormones probably has been but like that
has been in the cultural waterscape
uh for many years now
and
those people who identify as
blue and liberal and democrats and all
have kind of had to take a stand and
most of the people who are looking at
the medicalization
of kids who declare themselves trans who
don't agree with it and i do think that
that was a strong majority at least at
first have just been quiet about it
because they see what happens well to
people like us but especially to people
like abigail schreier right who wrote an
extraordinary and very compassionate
book
and she has just been vilified vilified
vilified right
um so
you see that you see that if you
question
not transness but the medicalization and
if you even talk about social contagion
as a causal factor
right then you get destroyed then you
get cancelled yes or they or there are
attempts made to do that then comes
along this
thing which increasingly i am adverse to
calling it a pandemic but like this
thing that we immediately i'll jump in
and say oh my god the pandemic
and we are sold
very quickly on this promise of uh
magical mystery vaccines that will show
up much sooner than we could have ever
imagined that happening before
and those of us who were skeptical of
the medicalization of anything
but specifically questioning
the wisdom of the medicalization of
children who had declared themselves
trans
were more likely to say
maybe let's let's see
and those who were either silent or who
had jumped on board with the
medicalization of transness we're going
to be much more likely to be like yeehaw
let's do this because we know that high
tech and high medicalization is the
solution to 21st century human problems
and frankly that's you know
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century is the antidote to that kind of
reductionist over technical
overtechnical over engineered thinking
in favor of a recognition that we need
progress but we need to understand
ourselves as biological systems which
are complex and not simple well and this
is uh
i think the underlying problem is that
we have supplanted
a traditional way of passing on
the ethics and methodology of parenting
right we have displaced
the you know what would have been a
religious framework in which we told you
what the job of a parent was and you got
the idea
hey actually i'm supposed to be ready to
trade my life to protect this person
um there are bad forces in the world
they may come for your child and that
doesn't leave you a lot of options right
that thing has been thrown out when you
become a parent you are no longer the
most important person in your own life
right
and in throwing it out what we didn't do
was replace it with something useful
what we left was a vacuum that has now
been filled with
anthony fauci and whatever else but it
was filled before by the schools right
like you know people really a lot of
people really thought that the schools
were supposed to be doing the job that
historically parents have done right and
there are a lot of us who are like yeah
no thanks um
schools
hopefully good for socialization uh
substantially less good at actually
educating
but in terms of teaching moral lessons
which is of course what a lot of the dei
stuff that diversity equity inclusion is
actually doing
many of us from the beginning like that
not your job
and no thank you i do not need to be
relieved of that job that is my job as
the parent and i'm going to keep it
okay that was a long answer
my three-year-old asked why thumbs
unlike other fingers are curved
seems useful for putting hands on the
floor palm not touching thumb like a
kickstand oh
keep them like a kickstand okay yeah
cool
this is echo asking who is a dancer like
breakdancers do
it proves that dance comes from monkeys
fish sponges cells
i don't know what the last part means
but
uh yeah why why why are they curved
unlike the other fingers
it does i mean it does it doesn't work
for this yeah exactly it curves back the
other thing i mean i think some people
can like curve their fingers back but
for the most most of us that doesn't
happen whereas the thumb and some people
can their thumb scrape way way back mine
doesn't care all that much back um but
uh
you know the curve may have to do with
the opposability um
such that um and i think i think i think
the big toe actually also has a little
bit of a curve to it and of course our
relatives have opposable big toes as
well i don't know who would oppose them
though
um
gotcha
i think it's going to have to do with
the thumb being shorter and mounted
lower on the hand and so in order to get
it to meet well
to meet flat effectively
it has to be curved back
that'd be my guess
well it's also
it's also on a different plane right so
the four fingers are all on this plane
and it's kind of like it
you you have to kind of twist it in it's
like 20 degrees off the plane
it's like the thumbnail like do this do
this guys um and look at your four nails
and you see that the four fingers uh the
nails are all in one plane are all um in
one plane i don't know how to say it and
the thumb is on us on a plane that's
about 20 degrees off of that yeah but
it's so it's rotated already it's
already rotated on the plane at the hand
and so an additional curve in the digit
would be an accommodation as well so
everything about it is different it's on
a different plane and it wasn't a
non-stop
aviation evolution puns okay that's
where we are okay okay i don't know what
it means but yeah it felt like it needed
to be
apparently
um okay next question if the lab coveted
creators
are making the grave error of believing
the feeble and cartoonish textbook
evolutionary story
placing a function gained viral hill
climbing program on the foothills of a
mountain range they know little about
and expecting to control its
evolutionary trajectory i love this
person who is that yeah this is the
archimedes effect oh okay so i'm gonna
leave out the parenthetical and get to
the end of the uh which was great but uh
i just read the question three without
the parenthetical if the lab covered
creators are making the grave error of
believing the feeble and cartoonish
textbook evolutionary story
are agi creators making the same error
uh our agi being artificial general
intelligence
uh yeah
absolutely that's the thought now the
question is how close are they to
producing anything that uh
is usefully dangerous and
just because they're not close yet
doesn't mean they won't get them well my
argument has been
they already did it to us and they did
it to us and we didn't notice because
it's algorithms not robots yeah right
they haven't gotten there with the
robots they've actually done better than
i thought they were going to
but
um
but nonetheless
the
the thing that is destroying the world
with artificial general intelligence
isn't artificial general intelligence
it's specific algorithmic
intelligence that is destroying our
minds through we've been parasitized by
heuristics we've been parasitized by
heuristics even the people who wrote
these things don't know what they do
and can't stop them let's put it can't
stop them and the world is obviously
manifestly insane so this is a strong
contender for the pathology that caused
that to happen
um and we ought to think about it yes
yes so yes and yes yeah yes
what oh gosh i love this question i
could lecture for hours on this question
i'm not going to i'm not you guess
what's coming
you have no idea what must the trends it
has nothing to do with anything we've
talked about today or for weeks even but
i used to find a connection okay cool
i'm looking forward to it
what must the transition have been like
as we moved from overparity to
viviparity
did shells get soft and become placentas
were there many stillbirths along the
way how much can we extrapolate about
the mechanisms
i actually thought at one point
relatively late in the game at evergreen
that um
i wanted to start
a research program
in the various reproductive transitions
including overparity the parity and
wait for it ovo viva parity so i have i
have hours of material that i could
yammer on about this about but um i will
say
simply because we just don't have
you need to define the terms okay so i
yes i will say simply what these three
terms mean and uh and mostly leave it at
that for now
overparity um
ovo
egg parody mode of birth um you lay eggs
as the way that you bring forth new life
into the world
if you are female
uh
viviparity viva live parody again motive
uh mode of birth so um we mammals um
other than the monotremes which are the
echidnas and the deadpool platypus are
viviporous we give live birth
and then ovo viviparity um egg live
birth what the hell is that
is in fact an intermediate stage and
persists in many squamates that is
snakes and lizards and indeed um in some
parts of the range of some snakes you
have um some that are one and some that
are the other and it's an environmental
response to the values and virtues of
either having your kid on you and being
weighted down with it as you are out
foraging or being able to leave it
behind having um you know left it an egg
somewhere um but risking it therefore
being discovered by something that wants
to eat it
and of course
there are you know additional advantages
once you know if you are oviparous once
that shell closes
uh you cannot as the mother
provide any more direct nutrients until
it hatches it is what it is and it's
going to you know you can protect it you
can heat it you can cool it within
reason
but you don't have any ability to
control
the nutrient load you know whatever
yolk for instance in an amniot was
inside that shell at the point that the
shell got laid down is what it's got
viviparity at the other end specifically
placental mammals being one of the three
groups of mammals of which we are we are
some um allows for the the greatest
amount of
changes in parental specifically
maternal
giving of nutrients to the offspring and
of course actually paternal influence
can
can make a difference to genomic
imprinting which is its own thing like
genes that came from dad are more likely
to try to draw nutrients from mom into
the fetus and genes that come from mom
alleles that come from mom are more
likely to
restrict the
fast flow of nutrients from mom to to
fetus so that um so that mom has a
greater chance of actually going on to
produce more that's one of many asides
that we could go to ovo viviparity
is this intermediate stage which not all
organisms that have transitioned have
presumably gone through but maybe
in which you actually retain eggs inside
your body and so you have an egg
which means there is no direct transfer
between mother and embryo once you have
the egg
but you have the advantage of carrying
carrying your babies with you wherever
you go so if you are in an environment
for instance in which predation
especially predation of babies um is
particularly high there will be a
benefit to you of overparity over either
potentially overparity or vivid parody
or i could clearly go on and i don't
know i'll stop there which i think is
the answer to the question
that the transition will have to have i
mean theoretically speaking i would
argue that
maybe there's an exception but that in
general the
uh
ova paris
creatures will have gone over viviparous
before they go viviparous
i hope i'm using the terms right but the
basic point being
there's a good reason to retain if even
if you're an egg layer
there are lots of good reasons to retain
eggs just the same way
that in marsupials a
kangaroo will produce a joey and then
put the joey in the pouch and the point
is all of these things are variations on
the same theme which is
there's a vulnerability to an offspring
left behind there is a cost to carrying
an offspring with you the
various ecological and
other considerations will detect these
the number of ways that mammals um do
this was actually extraordinary so just
you know put aside the the monotremes
the the egg-laying mammals at the moment
but um
you know marsupials can have three
dependent kids at a time
um they can have you know a
very early embryo still in in utero
uh a very young joey that has been burst
but is tiny and basically you know the
size of like less than a peanut that
came out is now in the pouch at the teat
and you know completely attached and
then a joey who's still um nursing but
is you know more or less independent
three very differently aged but still
fully dependent kids at a time
and you know there's lots of um kinds of
diapas and other you know reproductive
ways that mammals can control that the
female mammals can control their own
reproduction um and i realized that i
forgot to explain the final part of
overfill parity which is that those eggs
inside the body of an ovo vibrous
organism often a snake
um well a they're soft-shelled so it's
not hard calcified shells like we think
of with um with birds um
but they hatch just before they're born
and so you know they live as eggs inside
the mother and then they hatch and are
born right away so i'm going to guess
that actually there's an overvivi paris
stage and then
prior to the evolution of viviparis uh
birth you will have the elimination of
the shell
and that this will then set the stage
for
um
for the transition yeah
yeah and yeah there's there's a lot more
to say but
not right now
possibly seen as inflammatory by youtube
so feel free to punt on this question
but given the state of the world it
might be useful to talk about when a
society has a moral right to use
violence rather than election to remove
bad leaders
oh this is such a good question and it's
one that uh
i have been trying to figure out
you know it's funny
remember when we were in school like as
kids
we used to talk about things like the
founding of the nation
and the nation was founded with a
certain amount of violence
right we were in school in the
bicentennial so we got a whole year in
1976 a lot of
young kids in school then yeah um and
the point was
somehow even talking to small children
about it everybody understood
that
uh there were things in the political
landscape that would justify
violence right now everybody still does
know this
but we're not allowed to say it because
the point is all of the post 911 stuff
has been set up as a low bar that as you
begin to think independently or to look
at your leaders and say oh my god what
has taken those people over what are
they doing to us yeah you will trip over
these things and the point is oh
you're the enemy
the answer is no i'm not the enemy in
fact thomas jefferson
very famously uh said that the tree of
liberty must periodically be watered
with the blood of patriots and tyrants
and he was very specifically making this
point which was that tyranny is not
going anywhere and it is going to be
patriots that put a stop to it and that
is going to be bloody right and this you
know he
jefferson was like the anti-utopian he
understood that no matter how good a
system you erect it will be it will
decay over time and will need to be
refreshed right which is actually and it
anticipates so what i say is that the
founders
set up an evolutionary system they
didn't know it was an evolutionary
system because nobody knew what an
evolutionary system was and that's part
of the problem is that it keeps evolving
out from under us right and so you have
to build a process that counteracts that
but he anticipates this and he basically
says look
i don't think we've solved the problem i
think we've built something that can be
a solution and it's going to need to be
reactivated periodically
so anyway it's a great question i don't
know how where is the place it's not
discord apparently where is the place
where we can go have an intelligent
adult conversation about how it is that
people who abort violence know when it
is time to bring violence back how do we
have that conversation
it's imperative that we must clearly and
that is not anybody advocating for
violence it is simply pointing out that
this is a canonical that the question is
when have things gotten bad enough that
violence is the only answer right
yes
do you think i actually didn't see when
we started zach um can you just give me
a starting time or where we're at now
okay
okay
do you think ivermectin could be used
regularly to prevent virus like hpv
caused cancers
are you aware of any other cancers
caused by a virus
um yes the tasmanian devil tasmanian
devil nose virus um is that is it
is it is it is it like
i don't have a thought is it a
rhinovirus
no but it attacks the roster i forget
what kind of virus it is yeah but yes
there are well let's put it this way so
the first part of the question i don't
know i don't know about divermectin
there are various tumors that are
induced by viruses my guess is the more
we know
the more we are going to discover that
lots of things that we didn't think were
virally induced were
the lots of disruptions that turn into
things like tumors are going to turn out
to have a viral organ that's interesting
i am actually having
maybe the opposite but
not necessarily inconsistent with that
thought these last few weeks which is i
am suspecting that the more we learn the
more we are going to recognize how many
viruses we have as fellow travelers all
the time such that finding
some virus in a person uh will not end
up being
able to be linked plausibly to being a
causative factor i think i think they're
both true yeah i think that's better as
well and the scary thing in the case of
the tasmanian devils you have
effectively a contagious cancer because
it is the it is the virus that triggers
it now the question is what if that's
more common than we think yeah right
this is this is plausible yeah but i
would say
and that's not like that's not the model
for for cancer at all right
i am concerned in the case of the hpv
story that actually we have
a bad model and i'm not saying that we
do have a bad model but i am saying
there are things in play
uh in this realm like
um
telomerase
in the production of sperm that could
play a role in this story that we do not
understand and
let's just say it is a place where i
have thought
there's something about what we are
being told here that doesn't fully add
up but i don't know what it is that
that's bugging me yet so
i'm not saying it is not the story we've
been given but i'm saying
we have a system that we know blinds
itself
uh has confirmation bias is corrupted
when there's a product to be sold
and uh
one has to wonder indeed i will also
point out though
the hpv case and the hpv
vaccine is a place where there is a
question about
what the right public health response is
it anticipates much of what we've been
through with covet because in general
it's not 100 but in general boys do not
suffer from hpv though they do
transmit they transmit it yeah and so
the question is
what should we be doing about hpv and
vaccines do you vaccinate boys who don't
have a risk to protect girls
and the answer is that's a transfer of
health because these vaccines are not
perfectly safe
um so anyway it's it it is it is a place
where those questions are opened having
nothing to do with cope yeah uh do you
have any insight into the first part of
the question with regard to ivermectin
the first part of the question is do you
think information can be used regularly
to prevent virus caused cancers
well
what we know is that
it seems to be effective against many
kinds of viruses yep um
we need to know more about that yeah i
just i don't know anything about even
like our
our viruses that cause they cause
cancers to the extent that we know that
they're at least two and we think that
they're probably going to be more are
they philo genetically conserved like is
that a single evolution of viruses that
cause cancers probably not given make
out tasmanian devils and humans right
like probably not
in which case um you know what is it
about those viruses that allows them to
cause cancers and what is it the
mechanism of action in ivermectin that
allows it to be effective against
viruses and you know are those two
what-ifs you know what is are those two
mechanisms uh
sympatico with one another i don't know
i don't know enough to answer that right
and i would say that there is also a
question um about
uh
let's say that we found that ivermectin
was useful in this case there's a
question about how to preserve its
utility how to not repeat the failure
that came with antibiotics and
antibiotic resistance and on the one
hand
there's reason to think ivermectin will
be less susceptible but i do not think
it is not susceptible and the trajectory
the fact that the dosage necessary to be
useful
in the context of covid went
spectacularly up suggests with delta
rather than with the original variance
yep yep yeah suggest that this is
something to treat very carefully yeah
evolutionary explanation
do you sorry i'm just looking at various
questions here do you have an
evolutionary explanation of why nails on
a chalkboard sound so awful
ah it depends i can't even like read the
question without getting all shivery
some of us love it no you don't
i don't hate it okay that's different
yeah um
toby and i i actually don't know how you
feel about attack
okay whereas toby and i our 15 year old
and i both have like nah don't do that
so responsibly so what's that
oh yeah the metal on some of some of but
not all of the ceramic plates that we
have the the something about the glaze
on some of the plates gets both toby and
me when when metal hits it when
silverware hits it and not not some of
the other plates
for me it's not it's not actually a
sound actually
supposing we had a chalkboard and
someone was to scrape their nails down
is it
a physically painful sensation
physically painful
um it just it
it makes me
tense up everywhere
it it feels visceral sort of like gut
visceral but i actually feel it
um like in my like i have to work not to
punch my shoulders up and
well okay so evolutionary explanation
yeah i don't
pain
no but you know
deep visceral discomfort
so the question i don't i don't know
what the question was on service of
though what's that i'm just trying to
figure out what what would have to be
true in order
a it's possible that this has no
evolutionary meaning that it that it is
such an unusual noise chalkboard is
being rather new in evolutionary history
yeah yeah the the the noise is one you
just wouldn't encounter and uh
you know there's something in the
cochlea that causes a you know a
interference pattern that
is bad for your hearing or something and
maybe you just gotta make a particularly
shaped one that
some frequencies just get you
that kind of thing
um
alternatively it could be that it
mirrors some sound in nature that is
very ominous and therefore you have a
special detector you know being
dive-bombed by three giant hawks
right
um i mean it is it's a little bit like
the the the soaring cry of a hawk so
of all the sounds i can think of in
nature which you know i like but it's
not beautiful
i like it when i hear that outside
because i know what it actually stands
for and i go looking for the bird but
it's not a beautiful scene yeah but it
doesn't trigger any of the no revulsion
not at all yeah well it's not it's not
revulsion
visceral discomfort it's not revulsion
it's not disgust it's not pain
okay
um
i think you're all making it up um
evolution explanation uh yeah so i think
we're making it up okay so it could be
novel that it's a sufficiently unusual
noise that just does some unpredicted
unanticipated thing yeah it could be
that it is like some noise that has some
meaning that is especially hardwired to
catch your attention it could be um and
i don't recall anything like this nor do
i know of anything like it in toby's
childhood but
uh it could be developmental such that
people if you had
i can
i guess what i imagine is that like a
nail gets ripped off or something on on
a chalkboard like that's sort of what i
imagine might be the bad thing that
happens and of course nails being ripped
off is very bad um but i don't
you know i just i don't i've never had
that happen i don't my nails don't tear
so like it's not something that i'm
otherwise concerned with but it could
also be a like actually you had some
experience
um pulling your nails backwards and
having something bad happen such that
that is triggering you i don't know
maybe not yeah
i don't know i'm wondering also
so you had um could be a
an indicator of a warning as happens in
nature could be just a
hyper novelty that uh that
has no meaning
right
um i'm wondering
i should know but in the cochlea
lower
sounds are early in the spiral right i
don't remember i think so
so i'm wondering whether or not
effectively the scraping on the
chalkboard is at the high end of what
your cochlea can handle and if for some
people it intersects the very highest
thing if there might not be some
discomfort there
um and
for some of us either our cochlea
doesn't go that far which well i was
just going gonna say well but um it
might actually the prediction of that
might be that it's sex
linked
right that you know men typically not
having the higher end frequency
capacity as much
can hear it sure but they don't hear it
the same way and it might not be
triggering uh the the same response as a
result i think it's anti-sex linked
really yes that's the kind what does
that mean it doesn't put anybody in the
mood
okay
i mean i'm not wrong anyway
i yeah i i
we could do a survey
yes absolutely you go ahead and make
that happen oh no i was thinking of some
uh some kind of a form we could have
people fill out
that's
yeah no i'm not going to pull zach says
that's a survey but you were just
thinking of other things that don't put
anyone in the mood
having a form to fill out
oh
sure having a form to fill out being
handed one non-functional pen after
another standing in line
the dmv generally dmv
absolutely yeah
okay
okay um what's your take on trudeau
being castro's biological son
i'm for it
[Laughter]
i actually just saw a little bit um
jordan peterson was asked this on on
something and um
i'd like to stick i agree with his take
mostly although i actually read a couple
articles and i was like huh
the evidence seems kind of good that's
freaking weird and it doesn't change
anything yeah it just doesn't matter at
all and that was the part like jordan
jordan gave this answer he was like it's
disrespectful to mom and it's just it's
just gossip and like that's all true
well the it's just gossip part but like
there is some a lot of circumstantially
compelling evidence but it also just
doesn't make any difference at all and
the thing that jordan said that i hadn't
quite framed in this way was like what
do people think that communism is
genetic like you know like that's not
how it works so really at the end of the
day does it matter now right well i'm
going to connect this back and i'm going
to say that this is rather uh a lot like
the question of is it or is it not
um gene therapy that basically the point
is
um yeah that's weird okay well you know
let's put it this way um
he it's true or not he could be
yeah or he could not be
but he definitely sucks
you know what i'm saying it's like that
this is like
schrodinger's trudeau lineage
it doesn't matter the cat is dead the
cat's not dead the cat sucks one way or
the other
yeah
okay yeah
um
does enforcing brick in the wall science
kill creativity in science and ideas
yes yes 100
100 percent and the problem is that it
is hard to defend what you would have to
do in order to teach people to do
the
innovative
uh work at the frontier it's the most
important that it be done and it's the
hardest to teach and it is impossible to
defend
yeah
how in training was your academic
experience
it's a super interesting question
and you know that that we could both
write books on that um
one one of many many approaches to take
and maybe we take a few of them here but
the first thing that comes to mind
actually for me
is uh that when we were applying to grad
school and bob trevor's uh maybe the
greatest living evolutionary biologist
was our undergraduate advisor and giving
us advice of a variety of sorts
including go to a place with a great
museum
make sure you end up interacting with
undergraduates in your career a number
of things
um
but one of one of the things i don't
remember if this came directly from him
but i remember sort of in the stew of
thinking um as we were applying to
places and then once we arrived was that
at that time there were really at least
in um like evolution ecology and
organizational biology uh departments
and we were in an integrative biology
department but um for people doing
so-called skin out biology like organism
and up level biology
and i'm sure this is true in other
fields as well but at least within
biology at the time there were two broad
approaches
and one of them was you can't get in to
a department to a phd program say
unless you also get accepted by a
professor who has a space in their lab
labs metaphorical in some cases if
they're field biologists
who will take you under their wing and
the expectation is that
they have a research program and they
are going to be the pi the principal
investigator on grants and you will sort
of slot into one of the minor questions
and maybe you get to ask a minor
question that's related but you get
you know all of the sort of the goodies
associated with being under the umbrella
of someone who's already got an
established research program
but that does mean also that you end up
at the end of your
graduate work with a phd
but never having actually done
all the pieces of science from the
beginning to the end in fact you may
have done very little of it the the only
parts you may have done
might well have been data collection and
literature review which and you know
maybe statistical analysis but even that
was already getting outsourced a lot and
you probably didn't come up with your
own system your own question your own
hypotheses your own predictions your
experimental design have to get your own
funding um have to even you know write
it up on your own and figure out what
all that was
and the alternative and so that was
then already the dominant kind of
academic department into which you could
get admitted to earn a phd and so i want
to put one more thing on that one before
you move on to the alternative okay
the other thing is that sets up the
god-awful scientific world we live in
where pis routinely steal
from
their underlings and the basic point is
well
i was stolen from when i was in
underling and what you do is if you move
up the ranks you earn the right to steal
from your underlings and if they're any
good then they'll earn the right to
steal from theirs this is just the time
of life
yeah and here's the thing yeah
the thing that happened between me and
carol greider
part of the story i think is that carol
grider came from a part of biology where
stealing from your underlings is what
the pi does
and i showed up from a part of biology i
showed up from a lab where we were
actually
forbidden by our very excellent i'm
going to be getting you're going out
order you're making this very hard to
understand for those who don't already
know the story anyway but the point is
that system where uh stealing from
underlings is the expectation is part of
why the world looks the way it does
okay so that is the end result of you
being brought in and washing glassware
and then collecting some data on some
question you didn't come up in lab-based
science it might be you know washington
glasser is a little bit of a caricature
and certainly in field science it
wouldn't be that exactly but um but not
asking your own questions
and um
and it was already the dominant thing it
was already definitely the majority of
types of departments at the point that
we were applying and at this point it
may be the only thing left
and certainly throughout our years um
teaching at evergreen when i was
advising students who were hell-bent on
going to graduate school in biology
i would say i would describe this to
them and say
what especially coming from
you know a system where you've actually
been doing a complete piece of science
like you you went through my animal
behavior program you had to do
everything from beginning to end and yes
it was low tech and so you probably
didn't have to get grants but you had to
do everything and you will not be happy
pretending to earn a higher degree or
like actually earning a higher degree
working under the thumb of someone who
maybe it's been 10 years since they even
had an original thought but they
certainly don't expect one from you so
you know that's that's the dominant
thing and then the alternative which
michigan was the outstanding example of
and i think there were a few others but
i don't remember offhand what they were
was um
you you come in and no professor has had
to say oh yeah i want that person
they're going to come into my lab i'm
going to vouch for them it's sink or
swim it's like fiercely competitive and
michigan had a much higher um fail-out
rate among its graduate students in in
the phd program than any of these other
systems because basically you know you
if a pi has already said yeah i want
that person and that person and that
person or i can only take one a year or
whatever they're gonna they may be
relying on them to collect data and
therefore be much less likely to let
them drop out whereas if you get
i think our entering class was like 14
and i think maybe six of us ended up
with phds ultimately i'm not totally
sure of those numbers but it was
something like that
and
basically you spend the first several
years
um
i hate this metaphor but like shopping
around like
working closely with different faculty
and you know the first year there was
the you know meet the meet the
professors where people would professors
from all over the department would come
in and give spiels about their work and
then we would be
free to ask them questions and you know
we didn't do rotations
but i at least worked with a couple of
faculty before um landing with arnold
kluge who was ended up being my major
advisor who was amazing
but at any point if i had been like my
god i can't i can't figure out who to
work with i don't have a question why
isn't anyone helping me the department
would have been happy to be like okay
well then leave yeah right whereas a
department where you come in under the
auspices of a professor and therefore
have their funding and therefore they're
expecting your data to be collected
you're much less likely to be able to
leave and therefore
i think and this will seem maybe biased
and self-serving but i don't think it is
you are less likely to have students who
are graduating from those programs with
those phds actually be fully qualified
as scientists who've gone through all of
the steps they need to go through to to
call themselves scientists which is one
of the reasons that we saw such a
massive failure of science over covet is
that frankly having gotten your degree
doesn't really say that you know how
this is done right um which is
unfortunate yeah
so there's a ton more to say about in
training in academics but maybe yeah i
would just say a lot i i didn't get him
trained at all because i was never any
good at school and so
school just kind of failed uh to
reach me for both better and worse
um you know there was a lot of better
right the
bad parts of school can really get in in
the way and
so anyway didn't didn't have that effect
and i was incredibly lucky especially at
graduate school to find a lab where that
was understood
right
nick alexander was very unusual in this
regard and he you know he specifically
didn't want you working on the questions
he was working on yeah um and he was
specifically ready to
um
to mentor
work that was not in his neighborhood
that's right yep and um that was true of
arnold as well i think arnold may have
had a couple of students at some points
who did work on varanas and such and you
know like monitor lizard phylogenetics
which is one of the things that um
he worked
maybe he did i actually don't remember
he did a lot of work on a lot of
different things he himself was a
generalist as of course dick was um dick
alexander arnold clue he is still a
generalist
um
but his expectations of of me and jen
for instance um
who were his students together jen aust
um
were never that he that we worked on
anything like what he was working on yep
yeah
all right next question
don't we educate at the resolution of
ability
isn't that a form of marketing don't we
need to arm the suckers
people with low resolution question mark
i'm not sure what that means i don't get
it yet yeah um
don't we
don't we educate the restless all right
all right
a little bit i can't quite parse the
question but i think i know what the
person is
on about and what the answer is you're
gonna ask the question you think they
might have been i'm gonna answer the
question i think they were they were
trying to ask yep
um
in my opinion
and i believe this quite strongly
a
healthy
human
all healthy humans are similarly capable
at birth
this will not always have been the case
there have to have been differences in
capacity that were
genetically encoded in order for genes
that made bigger brains
to out-compete
smaller brains that has to have been the
case
but
in current circumstances
modern humans
i believe to be similarly capable if
healthy at birth and therefore what
happens that creates what is an
unfortunate and massive disparity in
capability of adults
is
different developmental
experiences
which
if that is correct if it's actually
anywhere near correct then the basic
point is we are leaving a tremendous
amount of value on the table by exposing
people who have the potential to be
geniuses to environments that do not
enrich their minds and leave them
hobbled relative to what they might be
that's what we're doing in my opinion
and so
anyway my point would be do we have to
arm the people who aren't so capable the
answer is they're only
not capable because we've failed to give
them the tools that would have made them
capable and that's really the thing
that's so tragic right you have this
incredibly high capacity brain
and we turn it into a feeble mind by not
confronting it with the stuff that would
upgrade it and there's no good reason
that we failed to we we could do that we
could at least
carefully
study the question of how to enhance it
and instead i think we're busy doing
other things like
making people
compliant
um
here's a comment
increased vascularity or
a hypothesis i guess
increased vascularity in men likely
explains some of why men have more
myocarditis
comparing compare the veins in the back
of both of your hands
much love from a canadian parametric fan
yeah more obvious anyway it's more
obvious and i and i mean we know
yes thank you for the uh
sort of immediate immediate check but
we yeah we know that that
men have more vascularized tissues this
is part of what explains um greater
aerobic capacity and therefore greater
athletic capacity okay
i want to ask you a couple questions
about what we apparently know that i
don't know okay um
what does it mean does it mean more
branching does it mean more surface area
what does it mean i i think
it's those two things which will be part
and parcel of the same thing that more
branching you know capillary beds have a
higher surface area to volume ratio than
um than arterioles which have a higher
surface area to a volume ratio than our
arteries like you know the bigger the
diameter the low of of the vessel the
lower surface area to volume ratio if
you control for body size if you take
males and females who are the same size
are males more vascularized than females
this is the
consensus i have not i've never done um
i only i've only done gross anatomy and
obviously not in humans rather so i
don't i
i understand that to be true but it is
based on other people's actual empirical
work
so i haven't i haven't seen it with my
own eyes
uh you know other you know that sort of
that sort of check like oh can you see
right but it's not obvious to me that we
would even necessarily you shouldn't be
able to
see at the level of um
obviously you know capillary beds you
can't see that through her well if
males are more vascularized because
males are bigger and therefore there's
more
you know if you were to count uh you
know
linear
units of
well but but linear won't do it right
like so
um
the highly branched tiny vessels in the
capillary beds
have
you know basically all the blood there's
a ton of blood in parallel but in
different vessels with a high surface
area to volume ratio through which you
can have gas exchange outside and in you
know into and out of whereas the gas
exchange that happens along a vein or a
heart an artery that's leaving the heart
or a vein that's approaching the heart
it's going to be much lower because
there's a lot more blood that's just in
the interior of the vessel that doesn't
have access to the to the boundary but
if i take a cubic centimeter of
heart is there something i can measure
that tells me this is more likely to
have come from a male than a female i
think so
okay
all right i would i would be surprised
but i
i think so but i'm not totally sure
all right
um so you could make an argument uh i
mean that's that's what this hypothesis
is based on and it you know you know it
does it's it's a hypothesis if informed
by the observation that men are more
prone to
uh myocarditis
big caveat for me i want to know that
the tissues are more vascularized rather
than the individuals are more
vascularized but by virtue of the fact
that they're just yeah no it's the
understanding that i have taken from the
medical literature is that it controls
for body mass
okay
so if that is the case then the point is
male
competition
which has all kinds of consequences
uh
makes males stronger and also makes them
shorter lived
uh more fragile in the end
that competition also
would drive the
it drives um
more extraordinary capacity the reason
that male athletes outcompete female
athletes and things like
strength even you know even if body size
is similar
uh has to do
with the fact that there's a trade-off
how much are you capable of and how long
will you be capable of it for example
in which there is more borrowed from
longevity in order to get
capacity and
greater vascularization would be
correlated with greater feats of
strength let's say
and it could result in a greater
vulnerability to
the mrnas ending up in um
that can't afford it indeed
all right uh we're at a little over an
hour let me find maybe two more
questions um
this is a big question i'll ask it but
um
thank you for such an enthralling
enlightening and sexy podcast what are
your thoughts on the pfizer date i
released from fda on the first
i've barely
barely dipped in at all but you're
talking about page 30
i
i don't know i don't know i don't know
what's on page 30. oh man i do uh
sounds like room
what's the room number in 1984
oh
we talked about it on his podcast anyway
page 30.
page well it's not just page 30 but it
starts on page 30. um yeah there's a
list
oh yes yes yes yes
i didn't know that was page 30. yes it
goes on like nine pages i don't know
what to think about it right because on
the one hand wow that's an impressive
list of adverse events
on the other hand i don't know
i want some i want a calibration right i
want to know you know the fact is if
every time anybody complained of
anything over some long period of time
after
being vaccinated you know the longer the
period of time you measure it
the less impressive that list is yeah
the more that list looks like a list for
everything else the less impressive it
is so i don't know what to think about
it but it certainly got my attention
yeah
yep
um
okay two more things
this is just a comment and then the
final question
people wake up to read news to find out
the anger of the day
some people don't do that
so that's just a comment wake up to read
the news to find the anger of the day
yeah it's you know actually there is
something
something nice in that in the sense that
especially i i cannot believe you know i
i i think of us as smart
but we are apparently not smart to have
banished our phones from our bedside
it's just become too complicated to know
what to substitute for them
um but not smart enough to have done so
yet yes yeah every couple of months
we're like god we really need something
an alarm by the beds that's not a phone
somebody should come up with a clock
that makes noise at a particular moment
in the morning but not but not something
that's going to just blare you awake and
and destroy the rest of your day right
and the problem is very frequently i
read on the damn thing before i go to
bed which is dumb in its own right but
yes um but nonetheless it has been hard
to get that thing out of there even
though it's pretty obvious that it has
no place by the bedside among other
reasons because we all have these things
by the bedside and we do tend to wake up
and find out what the anger of the day
is and then you know at some point you
have your coffee and you brush your
teeth and you guys i try not to butter
yeah now so i've read
i think i may have shared it on here but
i've read somewhere someone is like okay
if you
don't look at and they they weren't
calling it the anger the day although i
like that if you don't look at the anger
at the day um in bed first thing it's
probably on the toilet isn't it oh boy
yep
yeah and then
just something i think the problem is it
is too much power
for those devices which are hooked into
a small number of channels and
algorithms to synchronize our annoyance
so that we all you know emerge from our
domiciles primed for
a fist fight okay final question totally
different are you ready okay it's not
it's not horrible no i know that is
different right
not that the questions have been
horrible but the topics that we are
stuck on
are horrible could historically seasonal
diets epigenetically change people to
seasonally get kids with different
behavior giving astrology some merit
you'll never guess where
that hypothesis shows up
um we have it very right here yeah
carefully
laid out carefully laid out and i would
say you and we don't use all of those
words but no and this version that they
put forward is two is more limited
because it's it's entirely diet focused
right but i like it i actually had not
you know
yeah it's it's specifically about diet
but the point is as we make in the book
astrology absent um where you were born
uh can't have any predictive power at
all and that's you know that that is how
it is generally understood in in
modern times
but with the inclusion of place of birth
absolutely they're going to be seasonal
differences
well
it in principle could work and probably
has worked when place of birth was
included maybe not even explicitly
because it was just that the person you
were consulting was local no but i mean
i think
many forms of astrology actually do
specifically and explicitly include
place of birth yeah but i don't think
anybody has collected the data set that
would allow them to interpret that
information the point is if people who
come from saskatchewan and are born in
march have particular temperamental
quirks and that's a pattern that has a
reasonable
explanation right but the saskatchewan
march babies and the sydney march babies
um should have precious little in common
on account of their seasonality being
flipped right and somebody who was doing
you know so i think the point is it's
not astrology right it may once upon a
time have been
but
um the person doing it would have to you
know be sensitive not only to where you
were born
but how long you were there whether yes
we talked about that when we mentioned
this on air a little while back yep
whether the period of time
you know the five or ten years after you
were born in whatever location you were
born in were typical or atypical of the
you know if you had 100 year flood or it
was a famine like right now all bets are
off in terms of predictability but but
the basic premise of your question is
sound which is
that there are patterns that alter one
month from the next and where you enter
the cycle is going to have a
developmental impact and so therefore
people who enter the cycle at the same
moment in a different year are liable to
have some of those patterns repeated
so anyway yeah it
it does open that possibility but i
don't think anything that flies under
the flag of astrology in modern times
has the prerequisite of having tracked
those patterns as a function of location
of birth
all right
cool yes we did it well
we'll find out
no i think we already found out oh we
did it all right we will be back next
week for episode 118
uh which is also not prime you'll be
surprised to learn yeah yeah that
doesn't even feel prime
yeah nothing about feels prime um
in the meantime we encourage you to
consider finding us on our patreons with
the understanding that we may be
switching it up a little bit soon since
uh since you know all that missed this
mail information is about to get a lot
of people in trouble
um
check out the book check out hunter
gatherers guide check out
naturalselections.substantiate
um
yeah maybe that's it at least once this
week achieve greatness
achieve greatness be good to the ones
you love eat good food and get outside
be well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
you